ja oh ich bin ganz auf dem falschen fuß
erwischt jetzt mit dieser direkten
ansage jetzt kommt man ein großes blatt
welle für die deutsche klimapolitik nein
das gegenteil ich bringe jetzt ein thema
das natürlich unseren gast den herrn
paul
endgültige in seiner überzeugung
bestellten wird dass man nicht nicht
mehr einladen sollte hier ein stück weit
ernsthaft jetzt diese klimapolitik ist
für mich die größte gründe rung der
menschheit zeit journalisten gedenke ich
weil diese sich schon noch nicht lachen
weiters diese klimapolitik wird einfach
dazu dass die lebenskosten derart in die
höhe getrieben werden für einen effekt
der nicht einmal unter dem
elektronenmikroskop zu messen ist aber
die reichen die staatsangestellten die
bürokraten die das doch in ihren
geschlossenen abteilungen aus blüten die
merken nichts davon
aber die einfachen sogenannt einfach die
ärmeren bürgern die nicht das dicke
portemonnaie die werden einfach brutal
abgestraft man nimmt ihnen die mobilität
weg man vertraut ihnen das wohnen man
schreibt ihnen vor der alleinerziehende
mutter dass sie damit ihren einkauf
säcken und drei enthaltungen nicht mehr
mit dem auto zum einkaufscenter fahren
soll sondern liegen mit einer
überfüllten straßen bauen wo sieben muss
gleichzeitig anziehen muss für mich ist
diese klimapolitik ein sozialer skandal
und irgendwie der hohen besteht darin
dass ausgerechnet die politiker die sich
unter einem besonders sozialen
menschlichen da immer wieder turnen
nämlich die linken und die grünen dass
die hier die größte soziale spaltung
vorantreiben das finde ich gefährlich
und um das gleich noch vorweg sagen ich
bin nicht gegen umweltschutz aber ich
bin dagegen einen umweltschutz der
eindruck millionen in die armut rein so
jetzt bietet 2000 sie und zu lesen sie
alles
also erstmal finde ich dass es wichtig
ist dass menschen die eine andere
meinung haben ins fernsehen eingeladen
werden ich würde nie sagen dass man sie
dann nicht mehr einladen so weit es
ironisch ich weiß aber trotzdem wichtig
zu betonen und zum anderen müsste man
jetzt genau wissen was diese
klimapolitik ist sie haben da so ein
schönes bild gemalt mit vielen kleinen
strichen aber es nicht ganz klar was ist
die klimapolitik ich würde es mal ein
ganz großes thema bringen und sagen
energieversorgung welche
energieversorgung brauchen wir in
zukunft damit die soziale frage die sie
ansprechen nicht gegen die ökologie und
dann kann man sich ja die
preisentwicklung angucken das ist gerade
zu teuer wird mit der energie kommt ja
jetzt gerade als ich mal nicht vom
klimaschutz sondern davon dass die
chinesen den amerikanern das gas ab
gekauft haben und die russen uns gerade
keins liefern wollen weil der podium
findet es wieder ganz gut dann können
wir uns mal ein bisschen macht
demonstrieren mit der zweite pipeline
also sich ja nicht teurer geworden jetzt
innerhalb der letzten sechs wochen
klimapolitik sondern wegen vieler
probleme und wenn sie die preise
angucken neue atomkraftwerke pro
kilowattstunde 10 12 sind gaskraftwerke
mit den preisen die wir jetzt haben auch
acht bis zehn sind kohle ist so extrem
co2 schädlich oder werden sie es auch
nicht sagen dass man auf 50 jahre kohle
verbrennen soll das wahrscheinlich nicht
die zukunft ist auch schon bei 18
angekommen wohingegen solarstrom vom
eigenen dach geht für vier oder fünf
cent windstrom von der küste gibt für 6
7 8 10 also wir sind an dem punkt
gekommen wo die co2 freie
energieversorgung billiger ist als die
alte welt und dann ist es doch
eigentlich gar kein problem mehr zu
wechseln und da sehe ich das gar nicht
ganz gut weil ich muss sagen ich meine
ich bewundere natürlich ein paar weil
sie sind auch mathematiker und sie
argumentieren als einer der wenigen
politiker rational rational aber in
einem punkt muss ich ihnen da schon
vehement widersprechen die schweiz ist
das einzige land in dem sie eine
volksabstimmung gegeben hat über das
pariser klimaabkommen das ist den leuten
nicht so bewusst nämlich unser
sogenanntes co2 gesetz ist auf der
grundlage des pariser klimaabkommens
gemacht wurden und dieses gesetz ist
abgelehnt worden das war also eine
volksabstimmung gegen das pariser
klimaabkommen in seiner konkreten
anwendung auf der gesetzlichen ebene
warum weil eben die leute sehr
allergisch reagiert haben auf die
verteuerungen die diese maßnahmen
bringen und jetzt kommt frei punkt ich
akzeptiere dass es grüne gibt die sagen
wir müssen in diese richtung gehen das
ist ganz wichtig und auch die art wie
wir diesen klimawandel an steuern ist
wichtig aber da muss man auch ehrlich
sein und den leuten sagen freunde was
kostet dann aber wirklich geld und man
kann nicht einfach sagen das ist zum
nulltarif zu haben das halte ich nämlich
für eine unehrliche und am schluss auch
nicht erfolgreiche politik wir haben es
in der schweiz gesehen und von der
schweiz lernen könnte im prinzip
bedeuten dass man sagt wir müssen
ehrlich über die kosten sprich und die
tor verteuerung des benzins hat
natürlich soll auch damit zu tun dass
sehr viele fehler man gar nicht mehr
investieren in diese unternehmen der
fossilen energie und darum haben sie
dort natürlich dann auch steigende
steigende preise immer ein argument auch
noch mal nachzufragen war ja das ist gar
nicht toll die technologie ist so weit
dass der umstieg jetzt gelingen kann
ohne höhere erzeugungskosten hinnehmen
zu müssen warum sollte man es dann nicht
tun was man jetzt tatsächlich war muss
ist enorm investieren weil die alte welt
ist noch da sie ist abgeschrieben und
damit ist sie relativ günstig aber wenn
ich jetzt neue investiere in neue
erzeugungsanlagen dann bin ich günstiger
mit erneuerbaren als mit der alten welt
warum sollte ich dann weiter die noch in
zehn jahren noch mal eine sitzung
darüber
wurde jetzt ist er vor allem über
energiepreise gesprochen aber
klimapolitik ist ja noch deutlich mehr
beispielsweise die abschaffung dass das
verbrenner motors was ja nicht nur
energie ist sondern für deutschland
heißt das eine transformation einer
ganzen gewaltigen industrie die uns
erzählen so lange getragen hat und ich
finde aber nicht dass die grünen da
unehrlich sind selbst herr habeck der
war eigentlich ist eigentlich der
ehrlichste klimapolitiker der hat sich
auf dem parteitag glaube ich mai war das
hingestellt und gesagt die
transformation der wirtschaft und der
gesellschaft das ist ein unglaubliches
unterfangen und man hofft dass man am
ende mehr wohlstand für alle erzeugen
kann aber auf dem weg dahin wird es
unglaublich viele schicksale geben die
runterfallen aber das ist genau das wird
es geben für die transformation ihr
gehabt ist also wenn euch ein politiker
erzählt also jetzt gibt es ganz viele
opfer aber am schluss
aber
immerhin spricht ein politiker überhaupt
von ob nein das reicht ja so haben sie
ihn richten muss ich das muss ich
zurücknehmen weil da habe ich jetzt ein
bisschen aus der schweiz listen der
verwirrung gesprochen ich möchte ein
hobby doch nicht zu nahe treten aber die
versprechungen dass am schluss alle dann
quasi die eierlegende wollmilchsau
zu hause haben mir ganz gut stellen
neben dem neben der zuge wie praktikabel
ist es denn aktuell schon die neue welt
also wie viel von der alten welt
brauchen wir vielleicht auch einfach
noch weil wir den strom jahr zum
beispiel es nicht einfach so herstellen
können mit den neuen methoden also das
kommt wieder auf die bürokratie frage an
im moment ist es so dass sie in
deutschland sieben jahre brauchen bis
ich von der idee zur inbetriebnahme des
windkraft rates fertig sind viele wollen
es ja auch nicht es gibt ja auch gegen
initiativen die aus verschiedenen
gründen keine lust tragen dagegen in er
nie da gibt es alle haben dann dagegen
gibt da muss man sich ehrlicherweise
entscheiden ich glaube wir müssen da zum
legal prinzip überwechseln also das
heißt verstehen kann vor seinem haus in
den drei gestellte nein da gibt es den
abstand von 700 metern der muss auch
eingehalten werden 700 es nicht ich
finde es ziemlich ausreichend also ich
würde das machen sie mal da wir uns im
windrad finde ich okay aber die frage
wie man es löst ist meiner meinung nach
braucht es entscheidungen der
landesparlamente die über die
landesplanungsgesetzes festlegen wo die
windräder hinkommen weil alles andere
führt zu ewigen bürokratischen prozessen
und natürlich auch zu diesen streit
diskussionen wo jeder bürgermeister
wieder die grundsatzfrage der
klimapolitik mit seiner ganze
stadtgesellschaft durch nudeln muss da
kommt nix bei labor ist wir verlieren
was doch jetzt wirklich im detail
diskussion aber das liegt ja jetzt auch
ist da steckt ja schon gerne menschen
ist dass freiheit zu entscheiden ob ein
paar meter von ihrem haus ein windrad
hin kommt oder nicht genau und ich genau
und ich glaube dass die klimapolitik
wenn es nur darum ginge weit einem
windrad von meinem haus weg stehen darf
ich glaube da hätten wir keine probleme
aber es ist doch die geisteshaltung auf
ja aber ich glaube es ist geht vor allem
um die geisteshaltung auch den apple
meint schauen wir uns doch mal deutsche
klima bewegung an die grünen seien eine
partei der besserverdienenden freudiges
for future ist die absolute wohlstands
jugend auch gerade wenn man sich die
beiden schaffenden frau neubau und frau
reemtsma anschaut beider teams mclaren
muss man dazu sagen klar würde ich jetzt
nicht sagen aber zumindest aus der
reemtsma familie kommt
das ist das spricht ja schon wende ich
sehe ehrlich gesagt wenige arbeiter
kinder die auf diese demonstration gehen
wir mal 10 auch weniger außerhalb von
deutschland die das ähnlich intensiv und
mit ähnlich quasi religiöser inbrunst
durchfechten wollen einfach nur
glücklich den eindruck wenn junge leute
auf die straße gehen dann sprechen die
sofern sie für für eines der features
sind gleich für die ganze generation das
bezweifle ich sehr und sie sprechen
mindestens für die ganze menschheit auch
das bezweifle ich sehr viele menschen in
polen in peru auf den philippinen haben
ganz andere probleme als diese globale
transformation damit zu erkaufen dass
sie in ihrem alltäglichen leben durch
höhere preise in ihrer
selbstverwirklichung behindert werden
das halte ich für sehr schwierig und ich
bin das gerade durch sachsen-anhalt
gefahren es ist wirklich ein sehr
hässlicher anblick dort zu sehen wie die
landschaft verschandelt worden ist und
würde wer statt immer nur vom
klimapolitik ab und zu auch mal von
umweltschutz sprechen dann würden wir
sagen dass wir vielleicht manches wird
die klimapolitik tun was dem
umweltschutz schade das ist nämlich
diese extreme verspargelung der
landschaft und wir wissen ja alle dass
er bis heute trotzdem den strom nicht
von der küste bis nach bayern bekommen
ja es hat noch einmal wie was würden sie
reagiert ich kenne das von philipp ist
sehr gute argument ist es nur was für
reiche dann dass ich habe versucht so
dass ich überzeugt bin dass es
ökonomisch aufgeht das ist eben nicht
fünfmal teurer ist sich co2 frei mit
energie zu versorgen dass das durch den
technischen fortschritt heute billiger
möglich ist wenn das stimmt dann lässt
sich der widerspruch auflösen aber bei
ihnen würde ich sagen war nicht vor dem
naturalistischen fans also selbst wenn
das alles stimmt was ich sagen über die
freiheit ist verführt schon bewegung
folgt daraus gar nichts über deren
anliegen es kann trotzdem richtig sein
auch wenn da leute dabei sind dieses
religiösen motiven vielleicht falsch
vertreten weiß ich jetzt gar nicht
bewerten und ich glaube das anliegen ist
zutreffend wir müssen diese
dekarbonisierung schaffen und das
natürlich die branchen die jetzt zum
beispiel ölheizung und bauen oder
kohlekraftwerke herstellen dass die
nachher arbeitslos sind es liegt auf der
hand wie dieser biete oder beende diese
für seele wirtschaft dann sind die weg
die frage ist kriege ich neue jobs für
die da bin ich überzeugt das ist die
geben und die club- event aber keine
neuen jobs sehen